Thanos wiped out 50% of all living
creatures
[Music]
understands all these threads coming
together some of my family hunts in
every single movie all leading up and
they don't it totally heat cohesive
you want to have least have watched
infinity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what every company was the spider-man
Iron Man my father suddenly there was a
seven-year-old kid in a spider-man
costume became an inspiring costume to
see the movie it got him too
you and found a together our leaders
that are like these two powerful people
who have different being views you trust
me I do
she lost friends lost family who lost a
part of ourselves character is alter
their appearance for movie movie I
walked into makeup trailer and that's
how you can person ever and you had I
was like God it looks badass it was
really cool Bruce does have a really
great way of kind of reinventing the
characters not just aesthetically but
but emotionally mentally I just think
it's exciting for the audience it's just
an old message surrender
they only give you your piece of the day
you don't know the context of anything
else I like this one
I'm coming into something had been and
so much foundation so many roots so it
was just joining a family
[Music]
whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes this has been work
Steve I know it is cuz I don't know what
I'm gonna do if it doesn't
[Music]
let's go get this even if there's a
small chance we owe this everyone who's
not in this room
[Music]
[Music]